so we've got four ambulances on the way
in now so there's two inbound and two
expected and one's just arrived
they weathered the first and the second
wave
now they're bracing themselves for the
cold wave
seasonal winter pressure it's late
but it's here i think where we are now
um february going into march this would
probably have come a little bit earlier
we're starting to see what we would say
is our winter
the last week or two rather than it
start in january
so i think it's a little bit later and i
think the next couple of weeks are going
to be very challenging
the news of the road map comes with with
good news and
kind of makes us all very bit anxious
and a bit nervous as well
it's a triple whammy winter sick
patients who have stayed away from
hospital
are now seeking treatment and there's
still
a pandemic hi debbie
debbie fairbrother was rushed to
hospital by ambulance
after she fainted at work her daily
blackout started
after she caught covert 19 five weeks
ago
what happened to you as far as i know i
just collapsed
i don't remember anything i don't don't
actually remember it
coming on or anything like that no
morning
don't remember much to be honest i just
remember waking up and then getting in
there
the hospital is seeing a sharp spike in
emergency attendances
we've been here for nearly 48 hours and
at least
392 patients have attended
a d in that time that's comparable
to the busiest winter we've been filming
here for about 10 minutes and in that
time
about four ambulances have arrived now
that just gives you
an idea of just how much pressure there
is still on hospitals
like this one the hospital's intensive
care units
are still full of very sick covered 19
patients
but thankfully there are fewer now than
during the peak of the second wave
i think at some point lockdown has got
to be east
you know the government's in an
impossible situation when do you do it
numbers are certainly dropping the
pressure is certainly easing on the nhs
and we're starting to see more of the
normal winter pressure
we wouldn't be surprised if there wasn't
another another surge under the wave
hospitals across the country must manage
winter pressures
at the same time as cobit 19. infection
control
hot and coal zones and patient flows
new ways of working must be found
cardiac monitoring everything's in there
dr patel showed me the new pods
where he can treat and still protect
vulnerable patients
this area has been remodeled to take
pressure
off its emergency department you're
noticing the normal
copd asthma patients coming through the
door now
that we perhaps didn't do a little while
ago
and that presents another challenge
because we need to protect those that
have come in with
frail lung conditions from any other
patients that may have covered within
the hospital
so it's about creating areas like this
to like you say
mean that we've got a place to move them
out of a e as quickly as possible
it's right to look forward to the summer
the vaccines and falling infection rates
give us hope but it's also wrong
to think this emergency is over
ashish joshi sky news at warrington
hospital